voici ce qu'a dit le premier et le
dernier j'étais mort et je suis revenu à
la vie
ah mais je suis plus jeune que toi j'ai
leur plus notable après violent si j'ai
l'air plus
moi je porte pas à travers les bois qui
aime faire des kilomètres pour retrouver
le gac a volé ce téléphone
de tradition à laquelle ils seraient
fallu mais c'est normal
on attendait notamment
lawrence qui contient coupe et on voit
pas le localiser christian paul et
pourquoi tu dirais que comme ça tout le
temps dit un autre et celui là ce serait
bien de retrouver vite
ge est marié
des enfants
qui ce qui provoque alors des amis
j'imagine attaché moi ici mais contre
ifs n'ont jamais la loi ici de corps
en science 40 simplement rendu le
téléphone touchés
je connais plus comment
certaines un petit problème de voiture
c'est quoi ton métier toi un petit peu
difficile à expliquer